Welcome to Getting Started with
Google Shopping APIs.
I'm Danny Hermes, a Developer
Programs Engineer on the
Google Commerce team
here at Google.
I specialize in the two shopping
APIs, the Content API
for Shopping, and the Search
API for Shopping.
Today, we're first going to
talk about Google Product
Search and how it relates
to these APIs.
Then we'll discuss each
API at a high level.
And finally, we'll review the
technical resources available,
get our hands dirty, and write
some code using client
libraries provided
for these APIs.
Before we can talk about the
shopping APIs, we need to talk
about Google Product Search.
On May 31, 2012, we announced
a change on the Google
Commerce blog that will begin
to take place this summer.
Later this week, on June 27,
2012 Google Product Search
will be renamed to Google
Shopping in the US.
Throughout this talk, I will
still use the term Google
Product Search.
Here we see google.com/shopping,
the
Google Product Search
landing page.
On this page, we try to bring
the shopping experience to the
web by making it visually
pleasing and fun.
By typing for a query like
remote-control car, we see
results listing the most
relevant RC cars.
What's more, we can customize
our search based on many other
properties directly relevant
to remote-control cars.
For example, we can filter on
the type of engine that powers
the car, such as gas
or electric.
We can filter on style of the
vehicle, not just RC cars, but
also trucks, buggies,
and other models.
As we scroll down, we also see
the drive type of the car,
four wheel or two wheel, and
even the scale to real life.
All these features are made
possible by collecting as much
data as possible from merchants
and using it to
provide as much useful choices
to the end user--
the shopper--
as possible.
In order for an offering to show
up in Search results, a
merchant first must upload the
product and all the associated
data to the Google
Merchant Center.
Once this data is uploaded, it
can be used to power Google
Product Search, to drive traffic
through the Google
Affiliate Network, or to power
a merchant's site through
Google Commerce Search.
This data can be made available
on all Google
Shopping sites, depending on
the preferences of the
merchant and the programs
they're involved in.
So where do the Shopping
APIs come into play?
First, the Search API is just
one of the many destinations
that product data
can end up in.
It allows developers to
submit search queries
programmatically and receive
detailed results.
Second, the Content API for
Shopping is one of the primary
methods for uploading
product data to the
Google Merchant Center.
Merchants can submit their
data in two ways.
They can upload via Product
Feeds, which are flat feed
files that can be uploaded in
many ways, including directly
through a web interface.
Or merchants can upload product
data programmatically
through the Content API.
We won't compare the two methods
in depth today, but
simply note that each has its
own merits and the Content API
will be our focus.
As I mentioned before, product
data can surface in many
different Google properties, and
this manifests itself to
some degree in the Search
API as well.
There are three distinct use
cases for the Search API for
Shopping, one of which must be
specified with every search
query made.
The first is the public
use case.
This most closely mirrors live
results on google.com or
Google Product Search.
The second is the Google
Affiliate Network, or GAN.
This allows publishers to
partner with developers to
bring them qualified traffic.
A GAN search query will contain
results only from
those merchants affiliated
with the GAN
account making the query.
The product links in the search
results provide a way
to track this qualified
traffic.
And if a shopper navigates to
such links, the affiliate
sending the traffic
can profit.
The third and final
use case is Google
Commerce Search, or GCS.
Google Commerce Search allows
merchants to have the power of
Google Search directly
on their website.
By using the Search API, they
can send queries from their
site to Google, and the most
relevant results from their
own submitted product data
will be returned.
Now that we know what
the APIs do, let's
discuss how they do it.
Let's first start with the
Content API for Shopping.
In order to deliver relevant
results, we allow merchants to
send as much data about each
individual product as
they can think of.
This allows for the enhanced
experience we saw, such as
allowing relevant and helpful
search result filters.
As seen here, this data is
format as XML, and has data
specific to each attribute
to the product.
For example, we have a title, a
description, a price, and a
tax rule, among other things.
All of this data and more--
if the merchant desires--
must be contained in a parent
entry element as we see here.
The entry element comes from the
Atom XML namespace, as do
some other attributes
like title.
But the majority of the
attributes are defined in
other namespaces defined
as SC and SCP here.
As we'll see later, by using a
Client Library, we can worry
about the data we send and let
the library worry about
creating the correct
XML representation.
Once you've constructed the
product entry, you can insert
or upload the data by
submitting a POST
request, as seen here.
The API allows you to update,
delete, and retrieve products
as well by submitting PUT,
DELETE, and GET requests,
respectively.
Each request sent must follow
some basic rules.
First, each is made to a URI
based off the same root and
must include the Account ID to
identify who or what owns the
product data being sent.
This ID is associated with the
Merchant Center account.
In addition to a shared root for
the URI, each request must
be signed with an authorization
token.
This verifies that the user
sending the request truly has
access to the Merchant Center
account in which they are
changing inventory.
Finally, the header of the
request must identify the type
of the data being exchanged.
Here, we are sending XML in the
body of the request and
must identify it as such
to Google servers.
Upon success, we receive
a 201 HTTP status
code indicating success.
In addition to this, we also
see that Google servers
identify the response they're
returning as XML.
As we will see shortly, the
response is formatted very
similar to the request.
Finally, the header location is
set to the same URI we made
the request to, plus a
colon-delimited identifier
tacked on at the end.
The location is composed
of five basic parts.
The first is the root--
content.googleapis.com/v1.
And the second is the Account
ID associated with
the data being set.
The next part is the path.
When dealing explicitly with
product data, the path is
items/products.
However, the API also allows
operations on other data, such
as allowing you to
programmatically add new users
to your Merchant
Center account.
For this talk, we will simply
concentrate on the case where
product data is sent.
After the path, we have
the projection.
This is specific to the case
where product is being sent
and can be either generic
or schema.
The value dictates the format
of the response
returned from Google.
The final piece to the URI
is the Product ID.
This is a colon-delimited string
composed of the channel
where the sale will occur.
Here we have online, but local
is also allowed, followed by
the language of the product,
and the target country of
sale, and finally
by the Product
ID sent in the request.
In addition to the headers, such
as the successful status
code and location, we receive
a body in the API response.
This is also XML, formatted
identically as the request and
containing the same information
and then some.
We can see the same title,
description, ID, et cetera, as
well as some new information,
like when the product entry
was published and when
it was last edited.
Now that we have seen how the
Content API works, let's
investigate the Search
API for Shopping.
The Search API, intended to be
a programmatic relative to
Google Product Search, allows
submitting queries for
shopping data as well
as submitting
filters on that data.
As a result, this API has a
smaller set of operations than
the Content API for Shopping.
Since each query is only
retrieving data, the only HTTP
verb used is a GET request, and
the response is returned
from the API nearly instantly.
Each request sent consists of
the exact same route URI--
www.googleapis.com/ shoppinh/
search/ v1/ public/ products.
Rather than specifying an
Account ID in the URI, an API
key is sent with the
key parameter.
The query, filters, and other
settings are sent as URI query
parameters as well.
Since product data is divided
by country, the country URI
parameter is required.
As I mentioned earlier, there
are three use cases, one of
which is public.
The route URI ends with
public/products.
This indicates that we are
making queries against the
public source.
Google Affiliate Network and
Commerce Search queries use a
different value in place of
public, and this value will
depend on the GAN or
GCS Account ID.
Finally, unlike the Content API
for Shopping, responses
can be in either XML format
or JSON format.
By default, responses are in
JSON format, but a specific
format can be requested by
simply adding the ALT query
parameter to the request with
a value of ATOM for XML and
JSON for JSON.
When filtering results from a
Search query, we can use the
great deal of data associated
with each product.
We can define filters by using
the brand of the product, the
category of the product, for
example, shoes, as well as the
condition, description,
price, and title.
We can even query based on the
Account ID of the merchant
selling the product, the
Global Trade ID of the
product, or the link to
the web page where
the product is listed.
These attributes can be used in
simple filters to specify
that the product must have a
certain brand or must not be
from a certain Account ID.
These attributes can also be
used in more complex filters,
as we'll see in the
next slide.
In addition to using product
attributes, by specifying
certain URI query parameters,
we can define and
then refine our query.
First, is the most
basic parameter--
Q for query.
This allows full-text search
and follows the same query
rules that google.com
Search does.
Next, the restrictBy parameter
helps to construct filters
that match a certain
restriction, such as setting a
price between $10 and $20.
Using the crowdBy parameter, we
can create in effect nearly
the opposite of restricting.
Rather than ensuring all
results returned have a
specific attribute, we limit the
number of results from a
given attribute.
For example, by crowding by
Account ID and specifying 3,
we ensure that no account will
have more than three results
in our product listings
returned from the API.
By sending the rankBy query
parameter, we can rank results
according to some preset
ranking rules.
By specifying
rankBy=price:ascending, we can
ensure that the first result
is the least expensive and
prices increase as we
go down the list.
Unfortunately, there are no
relevant ascending or
descending ranking rules
associated with many of the
available attributes such as
title and description, and so
they're not supported
with rankBy.
By using facets, you can divide
Search results into
descriptive buckets, creating
a histogram based on the
restrictions you provide.
By specifying
facets.enabled=true, the
results returned from the API
will be facets rather than
individual products.
Each facet has a count
identifying the total number
of products as well as some
other data points identifying
the rules which define
the bucket.
To partition results into two
buckets, one of products less
than $10, and one of products
costing $10 or more, we need
to specify the facets.include
parameter with the value
price, followed by a colon and
a list of price intervals.
Here, our list of intervals is
the interval from star to 10,
and from 10 to star, where star
is a wild card indicating
the minimum when used as the
left value and maximum when
used as the right.
As you can see here, the search
results we have from
the filters we defined in the
previous slide are in a
dictionary JSON format.
The products themselves are
in the Items key of this
dictionary.
But before that, we also
have the total
number of items returned--
129--
as well as the current
item count--
25 returned in this query.
The title of the
first result--
RC Fast Wheels Car-- indicates
the name of the product.
And we see further on that
we have the price of $10.
Going to the next result, we
see a price of $10.07, and
even further, $10.99.
So as we requested, the price
comes in an ascending order.
Now that we have some context
and understanding of how the
APIs work, let's dig
in and check
out the Client Libraries.
For the Content API for
Shopping, we have Client
Library Support in four
programming languages--
Java, Python, PHP, and .NET.
These libraries are all open
source and maintained in large
part by Google engineers, but
also by other members of the
open source community.
For each library, we have a
comprehensive developer's
guide that outlines all the
actions you can carry out with
the library.
Each guide can be found in
our Documentation at
developers.google.com.
For example, the Python
Guide can be found at
developers.google.com/
shopping-content/
developers-guide-python.
And the other three libraries
can be found at similar links
simply by replacing the
word Python with
Java, PHP, or dotnet--
and that's spelled
out D-O-T-N-E-T.
For the samples, we're going to
using a dynamic language--
Python--
to demonstrate use of these
libraries in real time.
The repository for the Python
Client Library is hosted on
Google Code Hosting at
code.google.com/ p/
gdata-python-client.
The PyDocs Auto-Generated
Documentation can be found at
gdata-python-cli
ent.googlecode.com/ Don't
worry about writing these links
down, they're in the
video description.
The gdata in gdata-python-client
refers to
the Google Data Protocol
and family of APIs.
The Content API for Shopping is
a member of the gdata API
family and so follows
the protocol.
As we'll see further on, the
Search API for Shopping is not
a member of the set of APIs and
so uses a different set of
Client Libraries.
The first thing we'll do is
install on a Linux system.
The project uses Mercurial
for version control,
so we can use hg--
the Mercurial command
line tool--
to clone the repository.
So we're going to run hg clone
http://code.google.com/ p/
gdata-python-client to clone
to the local machine in the
gdata-python-client directory.
After cloning, we're going to
enter the directory, and we'll
install the gdata library
by executing sudo
python setup.py install.
And let me type in my
password real quick.
You may not need root to
install, but it helps to just
add sudo to the command,
just in case.
The client library in Python,
as well as in the other
supported languages, defines a
special class that handles all
the dirty work of creating
requests, obeying the HTTP
protocol, and creating
well-formed XML.
In the Python library, this
is called a client.
And we need a client before
we can do anything else.
To instantiate a client,
we import the
gdata.contentforshopping.client
module.
This module defines a class
custom tailored for the
Content API for Shopping
called Content
for Shopping Client.
Among other things, this client
is used to create the
unique URI endpoints
to make API
requests and to sign requests.
When instantiating an instance
of the class, we need to pass
our Account ID in to
the constructor.
So here, we have a client, which
is going to be equal to
gdata.contentfor
shopping.client.
contentforshoppingclient, the
name of the class itself.
And we're passing in Account
ID, the keyword to the
constructor, with the
Account ID 8721349.
And this an Account ID of my
sample account that we're
going to be using.
In order to authenticate,
we will use
the OAuth 2.0 protocol.
This protocol has three
main parts.
First, an application asks a
user permission and gets a
short-lived code.
Second, the application uses
that code to exchange for an
access token and a long-lived
refresh token.
And third, when the access token
expires, the application
uses the refresh token
to obtain a new one.
In order to carry out this
exchange to authenticate with
Google, the application will
need a Client Secret and ID.
To obtain a token, we need to
visit the Google API console,
as seen here, and create
a project.
So we're just going to
click Create project.
So we're in a new API project.
After creating the project,
we see a list of
services we can access.
APIs from the gdata family are
not on this list, so we need
not worry about the Content API
for Shopping, but we can
select the Search API for
Shopping for our second demo.
So let's scroll down
to find that.
There it is--
Search API for Shopping,
terms, Accept.
And now, it's been turned on.
After selecting a service, we
need to click the API Access
tab to create our Client
Secret and ID.
In our new project, we can click
Create an OAuth Client
ID to get these values.
We enter product name--
here Shopping-Apis-Demo--
and then proceed to
the next step.
Here, we specify installed
application since we'll be
running our demo from the
Interpreter rather
than from the web.
From there, we can copy
and retrieve our
Client ID and Secret.
You see here, 723174, et cetera,
is our Client ID.
And lowercase kg uppercase
K, et cetera,
is the Client Secret.
To use our Secret and ID for
the OAuth 2.0 protocol, we
import the gdata.gauth module
and create a new OAuth 2.0
token providing the ID and
Secret, the scope of access
we're requesting for the user's
account, and a user
agent which identifies
our application.
So here as the client_ID
keyword, we provide the Client
ID from the browser.
As the client_secret keyword,
we provide the
Secret from the browser.
And for the scope, we provide
googleapis.com/ auth/
structuredcontent.
With this token, we generate
an authorization URI by
executing auth_token.gener
ate_authorize_url that we can
visit in the browser to begin
the authentication process.
So here, I'll just copy that
and go over to my browser.
When you, or a user, visit the
authorization URI, they'll be
prompted with the name
of the application--
Shopping APIs Demo here--
and a list of all the access
scopes requested.
Since we only specified
googleapis.com/ auth/
structuredcontent in our scope,
we only see Manage Your
Product Data in the request.
Clicking Allow Access will
authorize the application and
provide the short-lived code
in that first step.
We copy this code, and we use
it to an exchange for an
access token.
Passing the code to the OAuth
2.0 token object, we can
complete the exchange
by executing
auth_token.get_access_token
with the string 4/-4, et
cetera, that we received
as the argument.
And there we have success.
Once we've done this, we must
authorize the Client with the
token so the Client can use
it to sign requests.
So we'll execute
auth_token.authorizeclient.
And from there, our Client
is now ready to execute
authenticated requests to the
Content API for Shopping.
Recall the basic attributes
needed to define a product
entry, such as title,
description, ID, and price.
As I mentioned before, the
Client Library abstracts away
all the XML creation and allows
you to just concentrate
on the product data.
The
gdata.contentforshopping.data
module defines custom data
classes, which aid the Client
in the creation of
well-formed XML.
So if we import
gdata.contentforshopping.data,
we'll have access to all
of those classes.
To create a product, we start
out with an empty member of
the product entry class, entry
= gdata.contentfor
shopping.data.ProductEntry,
with no arguments in the
constructor.
From there, we can set the
Product ID attribute using a
member of the Product ID class,
which comes from that
same module.
So entry.product_ID
= gdata.contentfor
shopping.data.ProductId.
And we're going to give it the
value SKU123 as a string.
For simple elements like Product
ID, passing in the
value to the constructor
is all that's needed.
To set attributes that are
shared across all gdata APIs,
such as title and description,
we're going to use the
Atom.data module, which
is also installed
with the Client Library.
So we need to import
atom.data.
And to set the title, we're just
going to set entry.title
= atom.data.Title, SwissChamp
Swiss Army Knife, which is the
title of that sample
product we saw.
So there that is.
For properties like price,
which also use an XML
attribute, we can specify
the attribute
using a keyword argument.
So to set the price similar to
how we did with the Product
ID, entry.price =
gdata.contentfor
shopping.data.Price.
And we give the value $66.95 and
use the keyword argument
unit to specify US dollars.
As you can see here in this
merchant account, we have no
products at this time.
This is the same account that
we instantiated the Client
with, ID 8721349.
Once you've set all the product
attributes, you can
insert by feeding the entry to
the Insert Product Method of
the Shopping Client.
So here, we're going to get an
entry back, inserted_entry
equals client.InsertProduct,
and we're
going to pass it entry.
The return value-- inserted
product--
will have the same values we
sent, plus a few more.
But it's still a member of
the Product Entry class.
As you can see, if we ask for
the type of inserted entry, we
get gdata.contentfor
shopping.data.productentry.
Now that we've inserted it, we
can go back to the Merchant
Center account.
After executing this request,
we can see our Product
Inventory now includes
the Swiss Army
Knife that we inserted.
We can use the existing inserted
entry object to
update the product
in our inventory.
For example, if we want to
change the name, we can set
inserted_entry.title equals
atom.data.title Swiss Champ
Awesome Swiss Army Knife rather
than just a regular
Swiss Army Knife.
And we can update by calling the
update product method with
the insert entry as
the argument.
So we'll get an updated entry,
and that will be equal to
client.updateproduct,
and we'll pass in
the inserted entry.
Returning to the Merchant
Center, we can see the product
name has changed.
So we now have Swiss Champ
Awesome Swiss Army Knife.
Finally, to delete this product,
we can call the
delete product method on
the Shopping Client.
So we'll get a response back,
delete_response equals
client.deleteproduct, and we'll
pass it (updated_entry).
Unlike inserts and updates,
the response is an HTTP
response object rather
than a product entry.
To make sure the delete
succeeded, we can check the
HTTP status.
So we'll first try to see
what is in the status,
delete_response.status,
and we got 200,
so that means success.
And we'll just check the reason
as well to see what the
reason was, so it's OK.
Just as the specification for
the content API is bigger, the
Client Library has more material
than the Client
Library for the Search API.
Client Library support for the
Search API for Shopping comes
in Python, .NET, Java, PHP,
Objective-C, Ruby, JavaScript,
and more to come.
As I mentioned before, the
Search API for Shopping is not
a member of Google's gdata
family of APIs.
As a result, it's one of many
APIs supported by the google
dash API dash insert language
here dash client family of
Client Libraries.
These Client Libraries take
advantage of an API feature
called the Discovery document,
which lists all the
functionality of the API in
a well-defined format.
The Content API for Shopping
does not have a Discovery
document, but the Search
API for Shopping does.
As you can see here, this
document lists the fields that
the API supports, describes how
authentication works, and
even describes the schema
for the API.
Fields here you see are
query, for example.
Again, we'll start by installing
the Python Library
on a Linux system.
This repository has been
registered with PyPi, the
Python Package Manager, so we
can execute sudo easy_install
google dash API dash Python dash
Client, just like that.
Before we can begin requests,
we need to create something
similar to the Shopping
Client we saw for the
Content API for Shopping.
So we'll start up the
Python Terminal.
Such an object can be
created on the fly
from a Discovery document.
In order to create it,
we simply need
the name of the API.
The Search API is named
Shopping, so we'll set API
name equals the string
shopping.
The Content API, on
the other hand, is
called structured content.
And we also need the
version of the API.
Both shopping APIs here are v1,
so we'll set version equal
the string v1.
In addition, for the Search API,
we need a developer key,
which was created for us at
the same time our Client
Secret and ID were.
Since we specified in that
project that we wanted to
activate the Search API for
Shopping service, our
developer key will be activated
and ready to go.
If we see here the API Access
tab, we can copy
our developer key--
A-I-Z-A-S-Y, et cetera.
And we'll paste it into the
variable Developer Key.
So developer_key equals the
string that we pasted.
From the newly installed
apiclient.discovery module, we
can use the Build function
to create our service.
So we're going to from
apiclient.discovery import build.
And we can execute client =
build, and we're going to pass
in first the API name, which
was shopping, as we recall,
then the version.
And we're going to use the
keyword argument Developer
Key, and we're going to pass in
the developer key that we
got from the API console.
Now you'll notice developer key,
the variable name of the
argument is in camelCase,
but usually in
Python, we don't do this.
Well, the reason for that is
because in the Discovery doc,
it's defined that way.
So, after creating this client,
we call the products
method to get a resource that
allows us to make API calls.
So we'll say resource =
client.products, and we'll
call that method with
no arguments.
To motivate why we're doing
this, notice that in the
specification in the Discovery
doc, the API actions are
listed in the products key.
So we're actually accessing
the actions available in a
corresponding fashion.
To make queries, we use the list
method on this resource
and pass in our URI query
parameters as keyword arguments.
To search the public source
in the United States for a
remote-control car, we call
response = resource.list, and
we're going to pass in
country='US', source='public',
and then q-- for our query--
equals 'Remote Control Car.'
And we're going to execute
that request.
For your viewing pleasure,
we'll Prettyprint this
dictionary to examine
its contents.
So I'm going to import pprint
for Prettyprint.
And then I'm going to
pprint.pprint the response
that we receive from the API.
And as you can see, it's much
larger than this screen, but
it's very similar to what we saw
when we made the request
through the browser.
To restrict this query to cars
between $10 and $20, we can
just add another keyword.
So we have the same command
from before, response =
resource.list and pass in the
argument, country='US',
source='public', q='Remote
Control Car', and we add
another argument, restrictBy=
the string price= the open
square paren 10, and then 20,
and we close the string.
And then we execute
that same request.
And what we see, if we
Prettyprint that, results very
similar to what we had before.
Except now, our prices
are going to be
between $10 and $20.
So you see here, we have
a price of $19.19.
Going up to the next one, we
see a price of $17.99.
So you see, the prices
are within that
range that we've defined.
Finally, to rank these by price
from lowest to highest,
we submit the same request
resource.list=country, et cetera.
And we add the rankBy parameter
with the value
price:ascending.
This is the same request that
we submitted in the browser.
If we Prettyprint this, we see
now starting from the bottom,
we'll get the item with the
highest price in the list.
So we start.
We see $12.99.
Then the next one up has a price
of $12.99, same value,
but not bigger.
Then we have $12.95, and we go
up one higher, another $12.95,
and one higher--
OK.
So as you can see,
it's ascending.
And there's an exact
correspondence with the
keyword parameters that we're
using here and the query
parameters that get tacked on to
the URI in the API request.
So using the Client Library
amounts to understanding the
filter parameters.
Thank you for watching
this video.
I enjoyed introducing you to
these APIs, and I hope you
enjoyed it, too.
For more on these APIs, check
out our developer
documentation at
developers.googl
e.com/shopping-content,
and developers.googl
e.com/shopping-search.
For questions, we're always at
the ready on the forums at
groups.google.co
m/group/content-
api-for-shopping.
And groups.google.co
m/group/search-a
pi-for-shopping.
And, of course, no need
to memorize these.
They are in the video
description.
Thanks and have a nice day.